hello going everybody day two of this
year's edinburgh tv festival and a very
special guest from the big and small
screen is taking to the stage today save
your guesses because here he is in
action
business is a
[Music]
competition conflict diverse
and i'm concerned you might be
soft the only way he'll respect you is
if you try to destroy him you've got
your game going on
i've got my game
and i'm pleased to say the man himself
brian cox is with us now uh you are live
on sky news please do not swear um your
character is very much known for it
choice language on occasion brian is he
not
say again
your character is very much known for
his choice language on occasion
yes yes yes uh he's had a terrible
effect on me because uh i i was not
really a swearer until i played this
role and now i swear all the time and
it's
it's catching
it's infectious
tell us what you're doing at the
festival
well i'm actually doing a lot of things
at the festival i'm actually producing a
show here which my wife has created
called she her i'm also appearing at the
tv festival tomorrow and then i've got a
book in the book festival which is
happening on monday so i'm quite a busy
lad one way or the other but it's nice
to be here edinburgh's i regard
edinburgh very much as my spiritual home
because i i started here in 1965 would
you believe with my i was the i was a
founder member of the royal icum company
so
i've known my auntie used to live here
so you used to come here as a wee boy
i'm a dundonian but i love edinburgh
absolutely and
of course it's this is the best time of
year for edinburgh you know because it's
so exciting what's going on you know
yeah great i know yeah i know that
you've been there you've uh started your
career on screen career back in 1965 and
we were talking in the office about some
of our fondest memories of some of the
characters that you've played this one
was one of them let's have a quick
listen
we will lose at one strike
most of our war material along with tens
of thousands of our own men
who then
will defend england
would you have us do nothing with the
nazis massing 20 miles off our shores no
i would have us do law
we're going to go back even further as
well though brian but what memories do
you have of playing churchill
well i i i
loved it it was a very you know uh the
the young lady who wrote it it was one
of uh alex von thompson one she it was a
very bold and very original id well not
an idea it's a contentious idea about
his attitude towards d-day which and of
course he
made such an error on gallipoli so there
was a nervousness which are in some of
the some of the books i think it's in
eisenhower's allen brooks book they
mentioned this kind of thing this
hesitancy that he had
so it was great and also we filmed in
edinburgh we filmed all around here so
it was quite extraordinary to film a
churchill film all up in scotland which
was nice
and um apart from playing a leader
you've also played a cannibal let's look
at this one
i thought you might be curious to see if
you're smarter than the person i'm
looking for then by implication you
think you're smarter than me since you
caught me
know that i'm not smarter than you then
how did you catch me
you had disadvantages what disadvantages
you're insane
you played a media mogul you played a
king you played a prime minister you
played a roman general you've played as
we saw there a cannibal which life have
you enjoyed uh playing vicariously the
most
um
i don't know it's very hard to say i
suppose logan is uh
is quite a fascinating character to play
because he's he's so mysterious we don't
really know how he thinks we know how he
acts but we don't really know any things
so i think
but i'm you know it would be unkind to
say that part i
prefer more than others it was like
being saying well he's my favorite child
not her so
no i mean i've been very lucky i've had
a great career and i've played a such an
extraordinary variety of parts which is
really what i believe acting is about
it's about variety so playing
parts from
goring which i want an emmy for to
churchill it's a great challenge and
it's a great way of ex
you know stretching my instrument and
i've been very grateful for that over
the years and had a really good time
doing it too
i literally can't wait for the next
season of succession uh kieran culkin
who plays um roman as we as we know in
the show says it goes in a direction
that he didn't anticipate can you give
anything away
uh well
kieran doesn't really anticipate
anything
actually at all he's not an anticipator
one way or the other so for him to say
going in a way he didn't anticipate i
think is very strange to say the least
no i mean we you know we do our stuff we
uh we're still sorting it out what we do
with the children and are they going to
behave themselves and are they going to
learn anything and we're trying to we're
trying to secure the firm and that's
really what we're continuing to do you
know so it's uh
yeah i mean
i don't know about anticipating anything
that
in a way it's not gone i think it's
going kind of according to plan really
well we're very much looking forward uh
to seeing it do you know yet when we i
should know this but i don't when do we
need to see the next season
uh well we're halfway through i've got a
gap because they're all filming in l.a
which i'm not involved in and uh because
i'm in new york so they'll be filming
the show will probably come out probably
february i would have thought would be
when it would come out february next
year
10 episodes to do so
literally can't wait it's great to talk
to you thank you so much for taking the
time to join us on the show i know that
my viewers were very thrilled at the
opportunity of listening to you talking
this morning so thank you very much
take care thank you all the best thank
you